listen I think I think social networks
right now are in a very funny spot we're
five to six years in so it's mature
enough now that people are actually
putting effort and money into it so now
we start getting into the real questions
of ROI is this really worth it and
what's really happening is these
platforms are so different than anything
that we've ever come from that I see
here's what I see I see everybody
starting to become cynical about a lot
of these platforms when what I see is
the tools not broken the mechanics are
broken right that you know the ROI of a
piano for keith and i is zero the ROI of
books for us has been phenomenal the ROI
of a piano for Elton John and Billy Joel
was quite a bit so the ROI is predicated
on how you use the tool you know in
theory a basketballs broken to me as a
money-making proposition it wasn't for
LeBron right so so he'll networks work
but we aren't coming off this is the
single most important point that I did
not make in the book we are coming from
a digital world where things were
actually quite scalable and automated
banner ads search engine optimization
email marketing these things actually
were quite automated social ironically
is very heavy human very heavy touch
very long-term we came from sprinting
and we're going to a marathon and most
of us aren't trained for this marathon
I'm gonna come back in look there